-Hello everyone.
I want to welcome you
to this CIFAR virtual talk.
It's part of a new series
of events
meant to shed light on
how research
can enlighten
decision-making.
The research in health,
of course, in public health.
But also in computing
and in many other fields
of human and social sciences,
in economy, in anthropology,
in geography.
How this research can
then help the decision makers
to make their decision,
at a key moment
where the governments begin
to open their economies
that were paralyzed,
as we know,
by COVID-19.
So, if you don't know CIFAR,
it's a global charity
organization
that is established in Canada
and that gathers the most
brilliant brains of the world
to mull over the important
questions
that humanity and sciences
are facing.
And, like many organizations
around the globe,
CIFAR, obviously, had to adapt
quickly to fight
against COVID-19
and throw new projects
and initiatives
that we hope to shed the light
during this series.
So, as for me,
I am Antoine Petit.
You've understood
by my accent
that I am French.
I am a computing professor
but I am also
and maybe especially,
at this moment,
chief executive officer of the
CNRS, which is
the biggest French national
center of, multidisciplinary
research
a public research organization.
But I am also a
member of the research council
of the CIFAR,
and which the mandate
is to advise the president
and the chief executive
on the formulation, the
creation,
and the establishment of
advanced research of outstanding
quality programs
as well as the closure
of these programs
once their mission
is accomplished.
And I have the great pleasure
of presenting you
Professor Yoshua Bengio.
Yoshua is the chair holder
in artificial
intelligence Canada-CIFAR,
in the Mila center.
He is also co-director
of the automatic learning
program,
biological learning of
CIFAR,
and professor at the Université
de Montréal.
He's part of the most quoted
and respected
computer scientists in the
world.
He's one of the pioneers
of profound learning
and he is mainly the winner
of the prestigious Turing prize
in 2018
with his two colleagues
Geoffrey Hinton and Yann Le Cun.
And the Turing prize is
considered, in a certain way,
the Nobel prize of computing
and that award
is absolutely exceptional.
And Yoshua, he will tell us a
bit about it later,
also directed the development of
COVI
the application for smartphones,
which aims to look for contacts
and to predict the risks
of infection to fight against
COVID-19.
Before we start, I want to
remind you that today's session
will last about 30 minutes.
And I'm going to take advantage
of my role as session chairman
to start asking Joshua
some first questions,
but you will also be able to
contribute to these questions
by using the function question
answer.
And do not hesitate to send in
your questions.
And finally, I will remind you
that this session is recorded
and will be available on the
CIFAR website
as soon as next week.
Without further ado,
I will give the floor to Yoshua.
First of all, Yoshua, thank you
so much for joining us.
And then, I'm going to directly
tackle the topic
and I think that it's important
that you start
by clearing up, what is the goal
of these contact search
applications
like the one you've developed,
like others have developed
across the world?
We'll get back to it, maybe.
And maybe, because it's
your specialty,
what is the role of
artificial intelligence
in such applications,
and does profound learning,
since you are, just I said,
a specialist,
have a role to play
in these applications?
-Alright.
Thank you very much, Antoine.
And thank you for these nice
words.
First of all, the use of phones'
technologies
to reduce the spread of the
virus.
The idea is to be able to give
information
to people who are
maybe contagious
before they infect someone else.
Because today,
we are facing a virus
that is very different from
other...
contagious viruses
and, in particular,
an annoying characteristic
is that people will be
contagious for about two days
before even having symptoms.
And, in fact, the peak of
contagiousness
is before having the symptoms.
As soon as people start having
symptoms,
they will start reflecting
on the fact that they might be
contagious
and, in general,
they change their behavior,
they will distance themselves,
they will pay more attention,
and so, a big part of the
infection happens
at the time where people simply
don't know
that they are at risk.
So, the different applications
will use
the knowledge of whom met whom
to be able to share the
information
between those on whom we have
information,
the person has symptoms,
the person got a positive
diagnosis,
and those who don't know,
for the moment,
that they are contagious
but who have been in contact
with these people
about whom we know
that they are contagious.
In the case of classic
binary screening
that we find a bit everywhere
in the world,
like in France
and many other countries,
what we try to do
is to simply detect
if we are part of
the at-risk category or not,
in function of the fact
that we were in contact
in the last two weeks
with someone who had a positive
test
or a positive diagnosis.
That, in general,
this diagnosis,
might come maybe a week
after the first symptoms.
Because people...
There isn't necessarily
a sufficient capacity for tests,
people will wait for their
symptoms to become more serious,
and, in addition,
it takes time
to do tests.
It takes time after,
with the manual screening,
for the people who were in
contact with these positive
people
receive the information.
So, the phones allow this
to accelerate a bit more
and to use the contact screening
that happened
through the phone,
often with methods that are
secure enough,
in terms of
privacy protection,
but also not perfect.
It's impossible to have
perfection in that sense.
Where artificial intelligence
comes into play,
is that we can use
other information
that the fact of having
a positive diagnosis
to transmit a signal
to someone with whom we have
been in contact.
In particular,
if we have symptoms,
depending on the severity of the
symptoms , the type of symptoms,
etc.
We have a certain probability
that we are sick.
And this information,
this probability of being sick,
can be calculated on our phone
and be sent
to the phones of people
who have the application
and with whom we've been in
contact.
And that, before they themselves
get the symptoms.
Because there are a few days,
after we've been infected,
during which
we are not yet infectious.
And so, if we can send a message
during this window there,
we can have a big impact
on the spread of the virus.
So, it's then that artificial
intelligence takes action
and it intervenes to predict
the risk in function of all the
hints.
So, the hints,
it can be the symptoms,
as I mentioned,
it can be the agglomeration
of all the risks we've taken
by being close to people
who themselves had a certain
risk level, etc...
So, there is the behaviors;
do we take public transports,
do we put a mask,
do we wash our hands often,
etc...
that can also come to play
and we can ask these questions
to people
to refine this risk estimation.
-And maybe, to continue in that
direction,
not everyone is a
profound learning specialist,
but, to learn,
we need data.
And finally, as COVID-19
is something new,
how have you succeeded at having
this data
that allows to
learning and get a more precis
diagnosis
than the binary diagnosis
that is sometimes done?
-Very good question.
So, indeed,
to be able to predict
an event,
like the fact of being
contagious, of being a virus
carrier, etc.,
there needs to be data
that associates the available
information
at the moment where we would
want to make a prediction
and what we want to predict,
like having the virus, for
example.
At the beginning, we obviously
don't have this data.
But we have other data,
epidemiological data,
coming from epidemiological
models that simulate
what can happen
in the day-to-day life
when people walk around,
go from one place to another,
work, go to school,
go to the hospital,
spend some time close to each
other.
And we've built such a model
and colleagues,
for example, in England,
have also built similar models
that allow to test
different communication
strategies
between phones,
information.
So, with these epidemiological
models,
we can simulate
what would happen if people,
by being given a prediction
that concerns them,
decide to change their behavior
and how it could affect
the contagions that would happen
or that wouldn't happen.
So, that, is the first step
and that would already allow us
to evaluate how different
approaches can be compared
between each other, from let's
say a theoretical method,
because these models,
it's not reality,
it's like a physical model,
it's not reality
but those are approximations
that are often used
in epidemiology.
The second thing is,
it's from the moment
where a system like this
will be expanded,
we can measure all the
information on the phone
that serves as entrees
to the prediction.
And then,
when someone receives a positive
test,
we can also save this
information
and it's going to form
a data base
to train
a pointier predictor
that doesn't only use
the few dozens of studies
that give us
a few epidemiological constants
for simulation,
but something a lot more precis.
In fact, it would allow getting
data on a scale that,
for now, doesn't exist
in epidemiological studies
of the illness.
But it would also allow us
to better understand the illness
and to do better predictions
of the risk.
So, there are the privacy
protection issues
because it means
that people have to consent,
if they want, to share this
data
so that we could train
these risk predictors.
-This aspect of privacy is
obviously very important.
As you know,
maybe as the viewers also know,
that was the subject
of a number of controversies in
France.
How do we answer the people who
say:
"Yes, but in the end,
the gains are inferior
to the advantages?"
Because, then, if I understand
well,
it is not binary.
I mean, a tracing application,
essentially, is obligated
to leave some data.
But, in the end, the pros and
cons need to be weighed.
So, what do you answer people
who say that the cons
win against the pros, in the
end?
-I think we need to have a
serene,
respectful, and informed
democratic debate
to decide, together, in every
country,
and, ideally, on a global scale,
what weight do we give
these different values.
Is people's lives more or less
important...
than privacy?
And it's not all black, all
white,
because privacy,
it's not that we're losing it
completely.
For example, the technic that
we've developed
with COVI will protect
the data just as good
as the way
that the data in a hospital are
protected.
So, we're not talking about
adding a higher risk level
than what already exists.
People also use
applications with Bluetooth,
etc.,
on their phone already,
a lot.
So, we need to understand these
new risks
that are added
and understand their advantages.
At the moment,
to understand the advantages,
what we have on what is
risk prediction,
it's only simulations.
So, we need to do
pilot projects.
These pilots would need to be
on a big enough scale
to be statistically valid
to be able to evaluate, in real
life,
what degree of...
how many lives it can save
in the end,
and so, be able to judge it.
-Did you also do studies
during the context of
simulations on, ultimately,
what is the percentage of people
that have to use such an
application
for it to be efficient?
Then again, I'm comparing
with France, StopCovid,
which was launched
nearly a week ago.
Only 2%
of the French population
have downloaded it.
And we don't even know how many
use it.
So, there are people that say
that, then, it's not efficient
and others that say:
"Yes, it's better than nothing."
So, did you have the time to
study this kind of threshold?
-There is no simple answer to
this question.
For example, it depends,
if you have 10% of the
population that use the
application,
but that this  10% is
concentrated in some places,
well, for these places,
it will be very efficient.
Then, we have to see what kind
of application we are talking
about.
So, if it's binary tracing,
like what is in most countries,
there are, indeed, studies
that show
that maybe
60% of the population is needed
to really have a big impact.
But with our calculations,
we show that, sure,
it is not a threshold.
If it's 50%, it's still useful.
If it's 40%, it's still useful.
If it's 30%, it's still useful.
It's just the use that
decreases.
So, that is something.
Another thing
is that an application
like the one we've built
stays useful
at a lower level
because it gives information.
For example,
based on the symptoms,
it will help us evaluate our own
risk.
Even if I am in communication
with nobody,
to be able to evaluate the risk
that I am to others
based on my behaviors,
on my symptoms,
there are dozens of variations
on these symptoms,
well that's something very
useful to help people make their
decisions.
Second of all, there is an
application like the one we've
put together
that not only does this
spread of information
between phones,
but will also go get data
to better understand the
illness,
to help public health in
identifying
where the outbreaks to come are,
in a way, to be able to
anticipate these outbreaks,
it is useful
even if the percentage
of the population is low
because, at that moment,
we will go
look at the aggregated data
on many people
or on an area.
We don't need everyone
in the area to use the
application.
If 10% of the people in
the area use the application,
we're still going to have a
signal
that will be useful
for public health.
-And if I place myself
on a technical point of view,
the communications
between phones,
it's on Bluetooth technologies?
(Yoshua Bengio)
Yes.
-And then again, in France,
there was,
and I assume it's the same for
where you live,
a controversy around Apple,
not to hide,
that considered that it blocked
in a certain way,
the Bluetooth connection
to this type of application.
How have you planned to solve
this problem?
-There are many solutions
possible.
One solution
is that we asked
Apple and Google to change their
protocol
in a manner that we find minor,
that doesn't touch
the Bluetooth,
but simply at a consent issue.
I don't really have the time to
dive
into the details,
but it is, according to us,
a really small change
that would allow, if they do it,
to roll predictive models
with their interface.
In the meantime,
or as an alternative,
we've developed a
detection of
Bluetooth proximity,
based on the work that's been
done in England
by the NHSX and that was tested
in the Isle of Wight
and that seems to give really
good results.
And, in fact, even has a better
phone coverage
than we would have with Apple
and Google.
In the sense that,
with Apple and Google,
there are older phones
for which it obviously wouldn't
work
because they wouldn't be able
to update the operating system.
-I'm reminding viewers that they
can ask
questions and I'll be their
spokesperson.
There is still a subject
we need to tackle.
I follow this from afar
because Paris-Toronto,
Paris-Montreal
it's not exactly
side-by-side.
But I understood that,
in the end,
the federal government had
decided not to keep COVI.
So, I imagine that it was a
deception for all the people
who must have spent a lot of
hours
and, probably many nights.
Can you still comment on this
decision?
-I think that the role of
researchers
is to offer solutions with their
science
with what is, in reality
art in technology and in
science.
It is not the role of
researchers
to make decisions for the
population.
The government represents the
population,
they made this choice in Canada.
I think they have their reasons.
I can understand
that
it's easier to explain
that we're going to use the same
kind of applications as the ones
we do in the United States,
for example,
in many other places.
And there's a fear,
maybe,
that the fact of using
artificial intelligence,
it pushes people away.
So, there are arguments that can
hold.
For my part, the fact of being
able to save lives,
and to help the public health
with more precise information
to fight the virus,
it should've won the round
but it's not up to us to make
these decisions.
-Of course, it's important,
actually,
as you say,
that we do not get mixed up.
Politics are here to decide,
and scientists,
to bring expertise.
But I think that you're
absolutely right
on the fact that it's not up to
the scientists to decide,
that would be a confusion of
types.
According to you, even though,
I imagine, it's not really a
simple question
but, in the government's
decision,
what was the part linked to
whether Canadians were ready or
not
to accept this kind of
application?
Then again, if I compare to
France,
there was a lot of controversy
and a lot of forums,
so, the for the against,
as we really love discussions in
France,
as you know.
It played a role, do you think,
or is it more a technical
decision?
-No, I think it's really a
political decision.
Actually, the fear of putting
something forward
that is then not pursued by
enough people.
So, we see, still, for example,
that in Alberta, where there's
an application that was
launched,
there is about 5% of the
population
that downloaded the application.
So, I think there's an issue
of succeeding in a political
move that is important,
that can be understood.
-And now, we finally come back,
you've worked a lot,
all your team and many people
around you,
what were, in the end,
from a scientific point of view,
was it just an engineering work
or, rather, what were
the scientific obstacles
that caused you the most
problems.
-Ah, I really like this question
because it's an example
of the type
we like to see
where, at the same time, there's
an application
that is interesting
and useful for the public,
for society,
but, while
causing scientific challenges
unheard of.
So then, unheard of
scientific challenges,
at the artificial intelligence
level,
at the automatic learning level,
was to work
with the privacy constraints.
Example, if we really wanted to
be optimal
in the risk prediction,
we would need to have access
to all the contacts collection.
Who was in contact with whom,
when, for how long,
etc.
With the graph of all these
contacts.
But, that
is privileged information,
too dangerous.
We don't want that any person,
that any government can have
access
to this information.
So, in fact, this information
is implicit
in the phone networks,
but it's never exposed
anywhere with our system.
Nobody can know
who met who, where, when.
So, we had to innovate
at the algorithms level
to infer this level of risk
with missing information.
And others, in the same kind,
where, in the end, we don't have
everything needed
to make a prediction,
but how we can come out of it
from a technical point of view,
at the level of learning
algorithms,
to still succeed in making
predictions
and train the system
without having
the real answer.
-We're starting to have many
questions from the audience.
And one of the questions a
little pessimist, I would like
to say
that is asked, is "Are you ready
for the second wave?"
If, unfortunately, I add,
we had that second wave in the
fall,
like some fear.
-Us, our technology is ready.
We're going to put our code
as open source
pretty fast.
And so...
I think that after...
it's a public debate
that has to continue.
With what is put in place
nowadays,
with the tracing, that I kind of
call binary
will not work well in some
countries,
and there's a second wave
that's coming,
maybe people will tell
themselves: "Can we do better?"
At that moment, the articifial
intelligence use
will maybe become something
that will be considered more
seriously.
-There is certainly in the
audience,
people who are supportive,
if I can say,
and who ask, in a certain way,
can the citizen or citizens
help convince the politics?
For example, there is a
consultation
that maybe we should review the
decision
and reimagine the use
of COVI at a higher scale.
-I greatly hope,
in fact,
that we consider creating this
kind of consultation.
Obviously, there will be
surveys, eventually,
at the discretion of discussions
in the media,
in public places.
But us, among our values,
there is the question of
giving power to the citizens.
So, in reality,
this kind of application,
if they are well designed
at the privacy protection level,
they are democratic tools
where it's not the government
that decides for us.
It's each citizen that decides
to do a bit of his share,
from a civic point of view,
to protect his community.
And, it also means,
be part of discussions,
democratic ones, public ones,
on the pros and cons,
and the issues.
And I hope we're going to have
more of these discussions
in the future and so, actually,
I obviously welcome
today's discussion as such.
-Maybe then,
since we only have five minutes
left,
and time passes fast,
does...
I remember, at the very
beginning, that you are still
the big specialist
of profound learning
and one of the big shots of AI,
does artificial intelligence,
and maybe profound learning,
beyond the tracing applications
which we've spoken a lot about,
were useful and used during the
pandemic?
-Ah, yes, there are many things
that are happening.
At the start, there have already
been many articles
that have come out on the study,
for example,
of medical images
to help diagnose
before the tests are even done.
There are ongoing studies to
better understand
the patients' risk.
So, not with the phone,
but from what's happening in the
hospital.
Which are the patients
that we need to take care of
in priority, for example,
or that we have to put
in an artificial respirator,
etc.
I, myself, got involved
in other projects
where we use profound learning
for the discovery
of new medicine,
or new medicine combinations.
So then, we use automatic
learning,
profound learning,
to research faster and more
efficiently
in the molecular field
that is the most promising
to the pass
these candidates to
biologists that will test them.
The set of combinations,
either of existing medicines
or new molecules altogether,
is too, too big
to be able to all test them
or even test a fraction.
-And in that field,
are there promising primary
results?
-There have been studies
that have identified
potential medications
at the individual level,
already,
and that was done,
and I think that it probably
influenced
the clinical studies in
progress.
Where we are today,
it is the combination of two
medications.
So then, I don't think the
results have come out yet,
but it will come in the next few
weeks,
the next few months.
Also, literally,
new medications.
What is interesting
with the medication
combinations
is that it's going to be faster
to unfold
because we don't need to test
if these molecules are
dangerous.
We already know what the side
effects are.
So, we only need to really
verify
that the combination of medicine
helps fight the illness.
It needs to be understood
that these treatments,
in fact, is also a last resort,
we can say
before the vaccine.
But a vaccine, there is a lot of
development
surrounding that.
But it's going to be long,
because, well,
maybe we won't find what
functions fast enough.
But even if we find something
that functions,
it really needs to be tested
thoroughly
because we cannot allow
ourselves
to give a molecule
to 99% of the population
and then realize six months
later,
that half of the people are
dying from it.
-That would be a problem.
We had a few controversies
in France, about this subject,
on certain molecules,
and I think that everyone
hears well what you're saying.
-Whereas antivirals,
we give them
only to people who are already
sick, in general.
-Of course.
And these questions,
the definition of new
molecules...
I think that defining
new material goes a little
in the same type of research,
does that present,
for the AI specialists like you,
new questions?
-Ah yes, absolutely!
It's an extraordinary source of
questions that are not evident.
For example, one of the
questions that interest me
is how to use
learning by reinforcement
to have a strategy research
in the medication field
that takes into account
the particularities
of that problem
and that is different from the
use
of learning by reinforcement
in the applications that we know
like playing the Go game,
chess or Atari.
And it causes new problems that
we don't know
at the manner of exploring this
field level,
to use the fact that there is an
issue of time to calculate.
In fact, we are in a kind of
race against the watch,
we have a limited calculation
power,
how we use this calculation
power optimally,
to extract the more information
on the possible candidates.
-Listen, Yoshua,
we have a minute left,
we have to wrap
this up.
There are many recurring
questions
about the COVI application
and the tracing applications.
With questions on how
we can convince people,
isn't the application less
bad...
It relates to the question we
already had,
isn't what the application is
bringing less bad than
what it takes away in terms of
freedom?
So, there you go,
you have one minute
to convince people
that next time,
they have to vote for,
if I can say.
-I'm going to take a very simple
example
that isn't covered by
the actual tracing systems.
Let's imagine that...
Antoine...
has COVID symptoms,
and that Antoine and I
have seen each other,
three days ago.
Three days ago,
I got infected
but I don't know it yet.
I start,
three days later,
at the moment where Antoine
starts having symptoms,
I start being contagious.
If it was possible
that I get warned
that there's a chance that I am,
because Antoine announced he has
symptoms,
we could save many lives...
and...
we can do it by not taking
any more risks
with our privacy than we already
do.
-Listen, Yoshua,
thank you so much.
All you have left to do is
organize
consultations for the next wave,
even though we all hope
that there will not be a second
wave.
Thank you to all the
participants,
there was over fifty
so I think we had a good
audience.
Thank you, thank you again
Yoshua.
Thank you everyone.
Until next time, for a new
conference of CIFAR.
-Thank you very much, Antoine.
-Until next time!